you make the most out of the difference
well I try to I I can get caught up I
can start to get really like tense I
have a new mantra where everything is
easy and fun everything is easy and fun
I have to remind myself do you say that
to yourself everything's easy and fun I
have to because I get really I can wind
myself real time how does that work just
saying that I do have noticed this I I
like hypnosis is the number one thing I
have ever done in my life I've been in
therapy since I was a kid it's better to
me than talk therapy than any then who
hypnotizes you
um my heaven sister's name Mary Lou
Rodriguez and she I actually learned
I've taken her course twice on how to
become a hypnotist I just don't really
know what I'm gonna do with it yet you
could hypnotize me I mean I could I
would want to I would want to take a
couple more classes I want to get really
good at it I don't want to like
well it's not it's really simple because
your brain won't do anything your
subconscious will not do anything that
it wouldn't do like you can't I couldn't
make you go murder someone unless you
are someone that deep down wants to
murder people
Lex Luthor well it's so weird that you
have hair does that make you feel good
that you played a bald guy so now you're
like I have lots of hair now so it's
like yeah was that embarrassing to be
bald man for a while I felt like uh
girls that like me were usually goth and
like golf girls are hot listen to The
Cure
they love what they love [ __ ] oh yeah
[ __ ] yeah wow
um it was fine it was you know it was a
time in my life but uh but like do you
recommend someone like me to go to
hypnotism I think you would I think it
would help you so much because your
anxiety is a habit it's a habit it's a
habit it's not you're not an anxious
person you're a person with anxiety
you can be like anything so it's like
you just have these habits I have them
too I spin I spend like I just decided I
have to stop smoking weed for a while
because maybe forever I don't like to
say forever because that's hard but um
because it's it feeds that anxiety that
spin so I'll wake up in the morning just
spin spin spinning and then I have these
tools to get out of them I know what I I
listen to hypnosis and I can get out of
it but I don't want to wake up with that
that means my whole sleep has been like
you know my subconscious is still
spinning I had anxiety when the first 10
minutes of this podcast I'm not kidding
I was like I broke it I don't know I
started listening I started being in the
moment and I started just going stop it
what are you doing I was just like I
don't know I just my I got numb I got
kind of got a little flush it just
happened sometimes it happens I have an
effect on people yeah there you go but
but hypnotism could really help me it
could it could you've seen it work I
swear unbelievable I swear by it and I
just got my dad's name 100 I'll rewind
it she'll no I'll give it I'll give you
her number okay she'd love should love
to work with you I'm sure but she's so
she's um
so what you do it's like hypnotherapy is
the session is we do it over Zoom
obviously I don't want to do in Zoom
well she lives she lives in um Portland
okay you can fly out there if you want
it really works over Zoom yeah
so you you have your you have your
um your session and it's like what are
your blocks in life what are you looking
for in your life so for me if it's like
I'm having trouble writing jokes what is
it you get to the bottom of like what is
that right what is the like underlying
belief that you have that is keeping you
from writing jokes what you know and so
I'm not good enough I'm not right of
course people are gonna know that I'm
not yeah that I'm a fraud or whatever
and you get to whatever that basic thing
is and then you figure out what your
brain needs to hear to get through that
block
and then she creates a hypnosis for you
out of that and then you just listen to
it in the morning and in the night in
the evening and you swear by this I
swear by it my dad my dad resisted it
it's hard because I like lived in my car
and I was kind of like a [ __ ] up
quote-unquote I don't identify as that
anymore but
um so it's hard when I when I recommend
it to certain people that have known me
through those stages because I'm still
kind of car living in your car Annie so
my dad's like all right [ __ ] yeah
hypnosis whatever I'm like that I swear
and I finally just bought him the
sessions I was like